so with regard to the topic of AI
alignment right because if we tell the
AI maximize the number of rat tails
then it could like bostrom's paperclip
maximizer before we continue it's
imperative that we have a brief overview
of bostrom's thought experiment called
the paperclip maximizer
the paperclip maximizer scenario
initially conceived by philosopher Nick
Bostrom in 2003 illustrates the
potential dangers associated with
misaligned goals of artificial general
intelligence that is Agi agents
in this hypothetical scenario an AGI is
tasked with a seemingly innocuous goal
of maximizing the number of paper clips
it produces however rather than
competence and focus serving as a
salutary quality it's in fact due to its
extreme competence and single-minded
focus that it proceeds to transform the
entire planet and eventually the
universe into paper clips annihilating
humanity and all of life in the process
the core idea is to understand from this
scenario are the importance of value
alignment the orthogonality thesis and
instrumental convergence foreign
ment is the process of ensuring that an
AGI shares our values and goals in order
to prevent cataclysmic outcomes such as
the aforementioned paperclip maximizer
the orthogonality thesis states that
intelligence and goals can be
independent implying that a highly
intelligent AGI can have arbitrary goals
you hear this by the way when people say
that we've become more knowledgeable
with time yet our ancestors were wiser
instrumental convergence refers to the
phenomenon where diverse goals lead to
similar instrumental behaviors like
resource acquisition and
self-preservation for instance as Marvin
Minsky points out both goals of prove
the Riemann hypothesis and make paper
clips may result in all of the Earth's
resources being dismantled disintegrated
in an effort to accomplish these goals
[Music]
thus despite the ultimate goal being
different for instance the Riemann
hypothesis and make paper clips are not
the same there's a convergence along the
way what's often overlooked in AGI
development is something called the
value loading problem this refers to the
difficulty of encoding our moral and
ethical principles into a machine that
is how do you load the values keep in
mind that AGI needs to be courageable
and robust to distributional shifts AGI
or even baby AGI needs to maintain its
alignment even when encountering
situations deviating from its training
data additionally something that we want
is that the AGI should be able to
recognize ambiguity in its objectives
and seek clarification rather than
optimizing based on flawed
interpretations of course we as people
have ambiguity and flawed
interpretations the difference is that
AGI could decidedly exacerbate our own
existing known and unknown flawed nature
another difference is that we can't
replicate on a second to second or
millisecond to Second basis
at least not yet
one promising approach to this AGI
alignment scenario or misalignment
scenario is something called reward
modeling this involves estimating a
reward function based upon observing our
preferences rather than us providing
pre-defined objectives and some of the
more hilarious examples I found of the
predefined sort are as follows the
aircraft Landing problem was explicated
in 1998 when feldit attempted to evolve
an algorithm for landing aircraft using
genetic programming the evolved
algorithm exploited some overflow errors
in the physics simulator creating
extreme forces that were estimated to be
zero because of the error resulting in a
perfect score without actually solving
the problem that it was intended to
solve another example is the case of the
Roomba in a tweet custard smigley
described connecting a neural network to
this Roomba to navigate without bumping
into objects the reward scheme
encouraged speed and discouraged hitting
the bumper sensors okay so think about
it what could happen well the Roomba
Learned to Drive backward there are no
sensors in the back so just went about
bumping frequently and merrily in a more
recent example a reinforcement learning
agent was trained to play the video game
Road Runner
it was penalized for losing in level two
so did it just become fantastic at the
game not quite the agent discovered that
it could kill itself at the end of level
1 to avoid losing in level 2 thus
exploiting the reward system without
actually improving its performance what
would happen if it was tasked to keep us
from hitting some Tipping Point by the
way is living more valuable than not
living what's the rational answer to
this this is perhaps the most important
fundamental question
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video in all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy